[Musique]
c'est tim on n'entendra pas durant les
quatre prochaines années
l' agence mondiale antidopage a décidé
de punir sévèrement la russie après un
scandale de dopage généralisé est
instituée par les hauts dirigeants du
pays les actes et russes seront donc
privés de jeux olympiques et deux
championnats du monde de plus aucune
compétition mondiale pour être joué sur
le territoire russe et certains athlètes
qui pourront prouver hors de tout doute
leur probité en matière de dopage
pourront participer aux jeux olympiques
et aux compétitions internationales mais
sous bannière neutre et sans hymne
national
le fondeur alex harvey récemment
retraité trouve qu'on aurait dû aller
plus loin ça prend des méthodes
draconiennes pour envoyer un message
pour que non seulement les fédérations
aux russes les fédérations
internationales
mais les citoyens de la russie 6e il
voit vraiment qu'au prochain jeu non
seulement n'est pas d'athlètes qui
représente la russie mais pas d'athlètes
heureuse du tout aux jeux olympiques
dans les grands championnats
là peut-être à l'intérieur du pays va
avoir et ils vont demander des vrais
changements et déchaîné le pourtalet
le premier ministre russe dimitri
medvedev a pressé les organisations
sportives à faire appel de la décision
de la marque la qualifiant d' hystérie
anti russe joint à moscou par radio
canada
diana maximova l'entraîneur du duo mixte
russe en nage synchronisée était
dévastée par la nouvelle pour manque pas
une diminution de la déduction totale
des foires nationales est atteint
catastrophe est pour moi une agression
complètement politique
il y a aucune éthique dans tombante et
avait en ce moment même si plaidant pour
la garder la directrice du laboratoire
de contrôle du dopage aliéné reste
estienne ayotte pense que cette décision
sera historique et obligera les russes à
revoir de fond en comble leur politique
sportive
ces mesures là vont les mettre à genoux
les re se rend compte que l'argent ne
peut pas acheter le sport présentement
ces fermes dans les prochaines semaines
va commencer un nouveau jeu de société
car l' agence mondiale antidopage a
ouvert une porte au dialogue avec les
fédérations internationales
tu saurais faire appel de la sanction
toute puissante fifa négocie déjà en
prévision de sa prochaine coupe du monde
de soccer au qatar en 2022 sud à un
événement largement subventionnée par le
géant pétrolier russe gazprom et on
connaît les liens d'amitié entre thomas
ce bac
l'ancien escrimeur et vladimir poutine
qui est aussi président honoraire de la
fédération internationale de judo
pour le moment les autorités russes ont
maintenant 21 jours pour se pourvoir en
appel devant le tribunal arbitral du
sport ici robert frosi radio canada
montréal